sometimes you sort of offer the music
air as some sort of fragile bloom into a
hostile space and you like please like
me you know don't heckle in the middle
of this one you know it's like it's like
church music in an inappropriate setting
or something sometimes it is very
sensitive and or there's a lot of sort
of a most emotion to it and a couple of
my recent records have been very
emotional in sort of inward and so it's
harder to you don't take those songs out
to the crowd in a way you need them to
be on your side where's obviously it's
often a bit more challenging than that
live these songs are very out with their
very direct they've got a bit more pace
and a bit more attitude and it's
fantastic to have that in the engine
room sort of thing all this different
gearing but it's also the way that I'm
feeling I wanted I'm look in the world
squarely in the eye and I I just can't
wait to sing out all this stuff and I've
already seen it have an effect we've
done a few shows already I can see the
music registering it's very direct so
yeah that's very excited well I think
I've had a break as well you know I was
a bit toward out so I'm full of beans in
that sense it's like really have a I'm
longing to just play the shows i mean
that that so yeah it's great having this
this record and what it's got on it
delight on more facets of my writing and
my head you know than than previous
records which were pitched sort of in a
certain place you know I've been in
quite an inward zone well I was post
Fame and post a few deaths you know and
the strain and my private life and the
strain of just being away all the time
and having young children and all this
stuff going on and trying to work out
how best to deal with it all it seemed
to send me in word but I I've suddenly
I've freed up and it's like it reminds
me a bit of my first record this record
it's very divergent it's not one song
that typifies it there's lots of
different types of stuff but in terms of
the ideas and the that it presents and
the weight of some of it I think it's
far more reflective of me as a whole
because people talk to me sometimes and
they I don't know what they're expecting
but they can't believe I've got idea is
all I give a or I might punch
someone in the face it's like one of
course I'm a human you know are you not
offended it's like life's hard to
swallow isn't it most of the time it's
like you can't move an inch without the
salesman pitching you on some
they've dreamt up it's like
it's a constant struggle just to stand
still not be overcome by a sense of
loathing and yet it's completely
wonderful as well I don't know so I
guess yeah I'm delighted with this
record in that respect I feel that it's
a it's a work of greater maturity in
terms of the writing and I do think
there are songs are there that are very
like things I've written before like
Jack door sort of ballads that people
can probably latch on to immediately and
that what all the songs on there I've
written some things sort of similar ish
to but it's just better constructed and
then there are things like nemesis on
there which I think sort of transcend
anything I've managed to do so far I
think they're much more elegant
construct than what I've tried to say
the same thing but I've not said it as
well
which is basic that's all we're up to is
saying the same thing in different ways
I've had a few records with producers on
various entanglements with them working
with merius on slow motion was a very
successful project and at that point I
just bought this big studio I really
needed a little help in learning how to
use it or to think within the scope that
it offered me so I just basically been
making records in a very sort of bedroom
way and that's how I'd found my sound
finally or learn to relax in the studio
a producer gives you objectivity you
know he's not actually playing the music
he's sitting there listening and
obviously it whenever you get someone
like that it can be very very helpful in
all things so and he supposedly helps
people to express themselves or relax
within the whole thing will try
something they wouldn't have tried or
has ideas I mean you know some artists
are pretty clueless and they need
somebody to do everything for them and
then you get but I think it pretty much
all the interesting artists will have
very strong ideas about how it should be
but some people aren't very practical or
they're not got very good people skills
it's a polite way of saying they're rude
twats and they need somebody who
can sort of get everybody working
together so you know they think they're
there's some sort of divine presence
that's going to come in and sort of
create magic so it's like anyways
sometimes it feels like you need some
external influence some objectivity and
a little bit of magic from somewhere a
little bit of guidance well I'd heard
merius he'd made lots of interesting
records and quite grand he was obviously
quite sort of Barack in his sort of
soundscapes and that was a completely
running contrary to the way that I would
normally do things so it made for an
interesting component combination but
this time around I think if the magics
happening in the band then that's what
you're looking for the producer to
create and then I knew exactly what to
do with this it was it was right up my
alley funny enough of my music but I
mean it was it
he didn't have to do much with it
because we were getting a live tape
which has a certain sort of thing to it
everything glues together in a certain
way when you record like that and you
don't need to lash loads of stuff on it
to make it sound convincing it is
convincing it's the real thing it sounds
good just as the naked truth of what it
is so overdubs and all that it was
obvious where the big gestures needed to
be made production wise but I guess I
gained a lot of confidence slowly over
the years about my own opinion and being
able to express it I think the big
problems I had in the studio when I was
younger as I couldn't really articulate
what I wanted I couldn't speak drummer
language or or engineer language I
didn't know what all the knobs did on
the desk or whatever but slowly I've
gleaned little bits of important
information and terminology down the
years and I can just about express
myself without pissing everybody off so
it's often people will get pissed off
when you're not trying to piss them off
you're just trying to explain what it is
you want but that all they know is you
don't like what they're doing right
there it might be that there are only
seven inches away from the thing you
actually do want but you can't quite get
them there
I'm wary of these phantom thoughts
because really I know I'm not gonna get
a chance to do anything for a while so
you think wouldn't it be good if or yeah
i've got all that stuff going on all the
time i sort of take notes and i usually
i stopped writing completely when I'm on
the road but for some reason they
haven't this time so I'm still the
writing the word part of my brain hasn't
turned off so I've got a couple of songs
i'm sort of finishing so I I guess
there's quite a lot of stuff left over
from this mammoth recording session we
did over the last few years and the few
unresolved things too and I'm trying to
resolve some of those and I'm having so
it's it's always ongoing and I think
that that seems to be the way that it is
it just it just keeps coming